hello
and welcome everyone to actin flab today
is
may 6 2021 and we're really excited to
have shauna dobson back
for mathstream 2.1 this is going to be a
fun
discussion diamond holographic principle
and
d square emergent time maybe you'll
teach us how to pronounce it
and what it is so thanks again for
coming on
this stream and really looking forward
to it so please take it away
thank you so much daniel i just want to
say your community is so supportive
and i'm so happy to be back for a second
talk you are all working on
some of the most you know profound ideas
um
here and so i'm really excited and thank
you for having me yay all right
so this talk i'm gonna go a little bit
into
the more like the diamond part because i
got some feedback on what are these
diamonds and what was she talking about
and so i was really excited that d
square is actually a d diamond for
emergent time
so um if i i'll try to do my best to lay
all these out
please ask um like daniel was saying
questions every you know
10 slides or something like that i'm
happy to answer it um i'm also
trying to constellate and weave together
this sort of
kind of grand unified picture so um
there's some drawings in here and i hope
that it's
fun okay so uh let's let's go um i'll be
talking about the diamond holographic
principle
and d diamond emergent time yay okay so
the goal i sort of talked about this
last time but
not too too in detail um today i'm gonna
actually weave together
this kind of new math with uh active
inference and let's try to put it
together and all work together
so the goal is like to take the
holographic principle which we're you
know
um um all aware of uh which was like
begotten by um
maldacena's uh you know a beautiful
gauge gravity duality between
anti-disinterface space and conformal
field theory
i have an idea to sort of reinterpret it
in terms of continuous k
theory and something i'm going to call
pro emergence so a pro
object is a specific object
kind of in category theory that's being
used everywhere
and it's sort of this idea of sewing
together a bunch of
kind of smaller things that are
self-contained to get a grand object
and it's sort of built into the very
structure i thought oh this is a great
idea
so i talked about k theory a little bit
last time which is this beautiful
construction by grothen deek
to actually look at classifying
very difficult objects using isomorphism
classes of the spaces so
it's like oh we can tell if two spaces
are equivalent based on their
equivalence relations
and i thought that's a very very very
nice higher
way of looking at things and there's a
new work uh by ephemoth talking about
continuous k
theory so again this idea of sort of
sewing together maybe
smaller k theories to build a bigger
object
so for this pro emergence right i am
fascinated by
time and i want us to kind of get into
it right how does active inference see
these uh
these sort of time streams like are
there little local times with little
thicknesses around them what is this so
in this
this idea of mine is pro emergence you
have a doubly emergent time that's
emergent on two fronts
so um you have a local singular
condensed time which is sort of the time
that we all experience this very like
you know i'm presenting to uh your
lovely community 906 a.m
this is like shanna's now right but
there's also like
you know alpha centauri now and the
unicorn constellation
now right so there's all these different
nouns and who's now is what
so you have these like local singular
time and then you're going to have
actually have this global what i'm going
to try to push for is a non-locality
in the diamonds so um to rephrase the
holographic principle and
kind of upgrading ads which is
anti-sitter space which is the bulk
which has gravity in it i'm going to try
to actually rebuild that from the six
functor formalism
so that's what you see in this figure
with these um sort of six columns
is the six operations uh from peter
schultz the telecomology of diamonds
it's so beautiful so imagine building
space
from a functor formalism which is a very
very specific
and then um
if you're going to get the conformal
field theory which has no gravity
um i was thinking okay so the gravity
list should could be in the pro-finite
condition of the diamond so you see i
have a bunch of diamonds kind of glued
together
and so maybe this gluing in the diamond
condition can
kind of you know replace the conformal
field theory so in this
um you can actually get a holography and
it's really interesting to think what
active inference thinks about
uh holography like what's the actual um
reflection what's the actual object so
you can relate this to strong and weak
coupling
you know whichever theory is strong
right has a strong coupling which is
like you know the tension um um
you know in the interaction terms and um
so you can relate
you know you know whichever one you know
has maybe a
a weaker coupling you normally use like
a perturbation theory the stronger
coupling you have to use the
non-perturbation methods so it's very
physics-oriented
um and you know the beauty and the
duality is that if one space is too hard
you go to the other space
so this is really fun and this is then
um the i sort of have this grand opus
paper
uh the dob21 you're like she refers to
it all the time
okay so the goal right so i said you're
gonna have this pro emergent thing which
is like has multiple
emergent times going on it's not just
emergent time but i think they're
all over the place so in that is what
i'm gonna call v stack time
so um a stack is going to be this
particular object that takes um
values in categories not just sets so
we're not looking at like
the set of continuous functions but
maybe you're looking at the category
um of you know of continuous functions
and every object in the category is a
continuous function
so you're getting this sort of grand
unified view
um of of objects which is really really
neat
i say v because it's it's going to be a
stack with a v
topology on it i think i spoke last time
that you can actually put a topology on
categories and that's what i'm really
interested in
so the beach apology is uh peter schultz
says
topology that he's using for the
diamonds and it's um
it's a nice fine topology and i'll go
into it a little bit
so the big questions that are driving
some kind of you know wild diagram that
i have here in the middle this con d
diamond is like what is the mathematics
of simultaneity
so i'm really interested in what we mean
by simultaneity
and we say two events happen quote at
the same time what time
is that um and is there a difference
and what is the difference between
simultaneity and non-locality
non-locality you know you have spatial
non-locality
maybe the view from a pair of entangled
photons um and then what does temporal
non-locality mean that time is actually
everywhere that there is no
difference in time between events right
you have events that are maybe
spread out into space but maybe they
happen at the same time
so i'm really interested in what kind of
mathematics would be able to hold
something like that right maybe you have
a bunch of multiplicities going on but
they're all at once
so um you know i'm asking what is
embodied cognition in non-locality
how could you actually reframe one of
the fundamental tenets of like
active inference based on
like reframe it and non-locality not a
progression but what would actually
happen all at once
so this is where i think um you know the
mathematics would actually help like
infinity categories and this double
emergence that i'm talking about so i
talked about infinity categories last
time
these are categories that have a lot of
a lot of rich structure in them and
you're able to
create morphisms uh between morphisms
and between morphisms all the way up to
infinity morphisms which is really
really beautiful
so maybe the claim maybe it's kind of a
wild claim is that embody cognition like
is emergent time right so um what am i
gonna
you know hopefully that's something that
can i can kind of show throughout these
slides
in body cognition like is um emergent
time
so again the basis behind emergent time
is was it always here
i don't i don't know was time always
here who knows and that's what i'm kind
of after
so in this diagram you see i have the
spa fq which is the attic spectrum i'm
going to go into on the other side you
have spa qp
which is the attic spectrum of the p
addicts the diamond interpretation with
a little diamond on top
you've got these two factorization maps
these xps from
fargs work on his geometrization of the
local language so
heavy math in this um which is really
beautiful on the bottom you've got
this y diamond se these are um
this is called the diamond
interpretation of the fog fontaine curve
this is an attic curve
that has an actual forbinius action on
it and so this curve is very important
it's used in
the language program which is a you know
the top a grand unified theory of
mathematics right now
so then you have these ln maps that are
mapping up whatever up means
into what i call condensed tea diamond
so the condensed category
is uh peter schultz's construction about
category of condensed objects i'm gonna
go into those
it's a beautiful idea about sheaves over
points so anybody in the crowd
who knows what a sheep is it's like a
awesome topological way of keeping track
of local data local data liquid data
local data like a little bag
and um so i can't like normally um you
don't you have shaves over spaces
but here's an actual chief over a
singular point and
so he's uh he and um uh um dustin
claussen have been like putting together
this really
um awesome uh lecture notes on this
topic so it's great
it's in its embassy and i think it's
great so that d diamond is um
a conjecture of mine that you take the
diamond i talked about last time
and you can actually extend it to the
infinity category of diamonds so i call
that d-dime
a lot of stuff in that diagram but this
is you know what i think is actually the
aesthetic
uh because it you know what if we could
actually map this to like um
you know a string theoretic
interpretation or something then you get
the grand unified theory of math and
physics
boom okay so um
let me open that just a little bit so if
you take
uh let c be the category of diamonds
like condensed c be the category of
condensed objects in c
objects are condensed diamonds right
that's what's in there
um let r be the reflective full
subcategory of condensed c
this is a subcategory where all objects
and are actually reflections
of objects in uh the bigger category
so it's very neat we have diamonds and
they're reflections
so objects in our reflections so if you
take d diamond to be the infinity one
category of diamonds you can extend
this to conde diamond so condensed e
diamond and you get this actual
um object so following precedent from
fargs amazing work
uh the fiber product of this diagram is
claimed a modulized space and a diamond
that's very hard
all right so that's uh that's hard
so modulai of v stack time so let's take
this condensed diamond and just
up it just a little bit so i have this
other conjecture right
let's take um so the way that you get
these diamonds
oh i don't have a figure all right i
have the figure of a diamond very very
soon the way you get the diamond is by
taking equivalence classes
uh certain prohibited equivalence
classes of
these objects called perfectoid spaces
which are like berkovich space it's kind
of like cancer objects
and so you glue those together and you
get a diamond well why don't we glue
diamonds together and get something else
so you can do that so if you can take
diamond equivalence relations of this
diamond curve then you can get a stack
and the v topology and then why don't we
work in the modulized space of v stack
so modular space
is this awesome parameter space where
each point represents an isomorphism
class
of objects so you're looking at so each
point like in this little figure below
um is uh an isomorphism class
and so the question is like uh you know
how do you move in a diagram like that
is it a chess board
is it can i only move this way and this
way and this way so i'm really
interested in like
what it means phenomenologically to have
something like this
and to start in the upper left like dot
and jump to the
like the bottom right dot so how do you
actually move through this thing so i'm
thinking that every point
of that moduli space would actually be
an incarnation
of the condensed d diamond diagram so
that that huge factorization with these
maps
would actually be each point and i think
that's actually really beautiful so
that's the
type of like grand unified theory i'm
kind of thinking of um
yeah so these ln maps play a dual role
of what's called topological
localization
localization is a beautiful phenomenon a
beautiful way of actually
constructing equivalences between um
between objects and so topological
localization passes through this
reflective subcategory so
objects are being sort of stared at by
their reflections and it's a way of
getting more equivalences and maps
so i'll just leave that at that so this
pro terminology this is a little mathy
but i thought you know we're
let's do it i'm not going to go
supermathy but i want to give you enough
terms so you know like what i'm talking
about
so for this pro which i think is very
cool the idea is that emergence
is built into the very space as a pro
object
and not as additional counter terms i
think the ai community the active
inference community does that as well
you want everything sort of built into
the structure as opposed to adding these
uh counter terms there's a lot of
beautiful like feynman path integral
work that has all of these additional
counter terms
um added to it and it's like i wish it
could just be built into the actual
space
so you can actually do that with this
pro terminology
right so a pro object all this is um
there's a great reference called in cat
lab that has all these definitions
so i'm pulling all these um and lots of
great lecture notes on any kind of pro
object
so what is a pro object a pro object of
a category c is a formal
co-filtered limit of objects of c so
basically roughly um what we mean by
this co-filtered limit is that for every
two
objects c1 c2 and c you have a third
object c3 and c
that they both get mapped to it so it's
sort of self-contained
you see it's built into the structure
you don't have to go off and leave the
category to find the limit
so you have a hom functor um
also so what you do you take s to be a
closed symmetric manoidal category
closed um i have the definition for both
of these symmetric minority means it has
a tensor product
and you take c and s in rich category
which means that it takes values um
the harm set of c takes values in s so
you have this enriched hom functor
which is written like this c takes in
two pairs um going from the product
of c opposite with itself whereas the
opposite is the same category
the arrows are just reversed 2s
that sends a pair of objects in c to
this hum object which is a collection of
morphism so look at that
you're actually mapping each pair of
objects to where it can go
right to all the possible paths and i
think this is very nice
so a closed category means for any pair
cc prime of objects the collection of
morphisms is an actual object
of c so everything is inside of itself
and it's sort of like a categorical
closure property right
if anyone's familiar with just the
closure property of um
that you learn in like you know abstract
algebra so this is called the internal
hom
object right so um five the pro functor
so with the pro terminology you can
actually have a profunctor which
generalizes the word
uh term functor so let's c and d both be
enriched over c the pro-functor from c
to d is an
s functor so it's enriched uh with d op
um tensor c over s so again taking the
pairs and mapping them over
so you can also make this into like i
told you this modulized space
right right here with the points where
isomorphism classes
um are each point and they can vary
geometrically and i'll go into what that
means
um and you can get stacks from that so i
think i'll finish the pro and then ask
if there's any questions daniel just to
wrap up this this pro okay
before yeah let's get the supers techy
stuff out of the way
um all right so what's also beautiful
and uh all over the language program is
the idea of a pro finite group
so you can either you can take this pro
language
this kind of multi-gluing and
self-containedness and extend it to a
profinite group which is a topological
group that's isomorphic to the inverse
limit
of an inverse system of discrete finite
groups so you have this inverse limit
over the discrete finite groups these
are finite groups that they all have the
discrete topology
and you have a collection of
homomorphisms that satisfy nice
relations
so my idea is like okay let's let's
let's
up the game even more there's a lot of
work about spectra
and prime spectra and this is also
growth in d where the spectrum of a ring
i think i talked about it last time
um is a certain um the spectrum of ring
refers
is a space where the actual points of
the space refer to prime ideals
so again you have this like point
referring to something higher than a
point
okay so you can extend that to what i
call a
formal spectrum so gothic had this great
idea of like including
infinitesimals and things so it's not
like you have a singular
now but what if we had a singular noun
with a little bit of infinitesimal
thickening on it
right like every every now or every like
local time of ours had a little bit of
thickening
and we could call that an infinitesimal
thickening and so
um he actually has the same idea and he
calls it formal spectra
so we say the formal spectrum spuf r of
a community of ring r and as an ideal
that obeys certain properties
it's actually the inductive limit of the
prime spectrum so inductive limit
um meaning like this so uh the
the pro refers to a projective phenomena
on the end refers to an inductive so
it's like a co-limit
so spf r is the co limit of spec r um i
n which is um the where r is complete
with the i
attic topology there's various ways of
completing rings in the i attic
so um where the connective morphisms are
these closed nil potent immersions
spec r-i-n immersed
with spec uh r i n plus one so these are
of affine schemes and the co-limit is
taken in the category of topologically
ringed spaces so
uh what is a what is a closed nilpotenum
not
a available sheath which is again this
kind of thickening thing so imagine a
space with a little bit of like skin
on it and so i'm thinking that okay it's
not just a pro emergence of points it's
a pro emergence of these
formal spectra which are like times
intervals with little thickenings on
them so nilput and elephants uh and i
say elephants and no
nail pold and elephants nilpoten
elements are
our infinitesimal neighborhoods and so a
beautiful
way to complete again to complete the
ring you know having convergence issues
like settled
is to actually take added completion so
added completion is to actually have all
the infinite testable neighborhoods
at once and i think that's a grand goal
and anybody after added completion to
have all the thickenings right
um is what is probably what we should be
after
any questions on that so far before i
get to the fun
just like i yep okay thanks for this um
interesting intro i think one thing
that's really gonna
resonate with people hopefully of all
different
backgrounds is what you said about we
want emergence built into the base
structure of our model not a counter
term which isn't
a term that's familiar to me but it's
kind of like magic
shouldn't be added at the higher level
we should have a model
where at the base level we have
emergence and then you um mentioned
the pairs of objects and a few different
kind of pair operations like inverses
and so i was just wondering how should
we think about these pairs of objects
for example are they organisms
in the niche or are they two organisms
because if so then we can kind of think
every time you say pair
we might be able to like map it on to
something that that
we've talked about from the embodied
cognitive perspective
oh i like that yeah go ahead try that
try that um
you know well you could take you know
the category c of organisms and then it
could be
um any two organisms in the actual
category if you wanted the category
you know to be um you know pairs of
organisms like uh the organism daniel an
organism shanna or something different
then you could actually construct the
category to be that that's the beauty of
category theory
you construct it to be whatever you want
because structurally
you know the goal the goal is to get
everything built
inside the actual space and to have
these consistency issues
that you're not like oh well
yeah you know so like uh we come online
and then there's this counter term oops
so you actually have it
um where organism you know is
relating to or interacting with like
organism right
or you could actually have a category b
just the way that my organism is
identifying and
interpreting information like whatever
you want those objects to be it's
completely loose
cool thanks and i'll relay any questions
from live chat in another
10 slides yay awesome okay this is so
great yay so we're all on the same page
um you know built it build it into the
structure you know
and if you want the structure centered
around you know you can actually have
this c3 being like
the organism daniel the organism shanna
that everything maps back to me
because that's what we're doing right
inactive everything comes back to me
i'm trying to process um okay cool
all right so um okay this is a
i don't know these ideas may just all be
wild but i'm glad you know i'm here to
help right
so i don't know this is where my brain
thinks okay
so we have the idea of an infomorphism
which is an actual
pair of an adjoint pair of functors
that's on a chew space
and my colleague my great colleague
chris fields has done so much work
with that you know chris fields pairs
with levin all the time they come up
with this great step
so an infomorphism is one pair one set
of adjoint uh
functors which um um which satisfy some
information
my idea is to make a two infomorphism
from these six functor formulas so in
these
kind of wild equations down here the two
tails is
is a structural property an internal hom
and an actual tensor product how you
actually combine things
but the four in the middle represent two
pairs of adjoint functors so if
one set of two pairs is infomorphism i
just want to actually construct
a two infomorphism which would actually
be
a morphism between morphism so that's a
categorical thing at this point
we're working on the semantics of what
that actually means right now
and so bear with us that should be out
very very soon
so what is this the idea is the
incarnation of global time emerges from
diamond non-locality what i just tried
to say local time emerges from these
singular condensed
sets the two infomorphism is going to
connect
the global time with the local time
that's the whole point right that's how
your organism evolves
right uh that's how you deduce is to
connect
your local time with what's actually
happening globally right these cannot be
singularly they have to intersect at
some point
so if this two infomorphism can actually
do that then you can actually get this
temporal simultaneity non-locality i'm
still not convinced that there is a
difference
between simultaneity and non-locality i
would love it for anyone and you're um
you know if anyone's um
like interested in that that's that's
really that's tricky
because uh maybe maybe the instance of
simultaneity
is a slice of the non-locality or maybe
we were actually
in tune enough with what's happening
like
um like embodied cognition-wise or
whatever that we were actually
able to access for just a second
maybe the true non-locality of
everything that is the non-locality of
information whatever you want to call it
what is the difference i don't really
know
uh people normally refer to like special
relativity in reference frames
and i i have a couple questions about
what reference frames are
so um anytime you know i i think i'm
gonna
tackle a new subject i invent a new
dictionary i'm like okay let's start
with a dictionary to actually translate
what i'm talking about
okay so the notion of a site in category
theory
is where i can put a topology so i'm
thinking if i'm
you know for instance looking at the
site over you know organism
you know investigating its environment
something like this the site of shanna
that couldn't that's a categorical
categorical way of actually
um referring to the localization
phenomena and the collapse
right so quantum mechanics is saying you
go from you know the collapse of the
wave function
is uh great i go from a simultaneous
like super position
state to like a localized now of course
there's you know
controversy about the collapse and
things like that that's why i'm using
the word localization you localize and
then now
so um coupling perturbation right so
again strong coupling you have to use
these um
um these non-perturbative methods weak
coupling you can use perturbation
there's a i think there's a link between
perturbation and this perfectoid stuff
that i've been looking at
so there's a way called uh called
tilting to go from uh characteristic
zero if people are familiar with that to
characteristic p
you can also add these beautiful objects
called uh p divisible formal group laws
uh which are um uh you know once again
uh i would say ways of connecting like
groups um
the kernels of these actual maps are p
to the end torsion
so the torsion element um actually
annihilates any other element
so an element is torsion if it actually
um is annihilated by another element
so you can see that you have these p to
the n sort of phenomena that are
canceling terms
so the whole idea is that you can get
this cancellation and sort of a
sequence phenomena um also in perpecute
spaces
so there's also torsion in these objects
called shimura varieties which we'll
talk about later that's in the language
conjecture
strong coupling maybe it's strong uh you
know maybe
in the diamond we could say strong
coupling is in the diamond side of the
holography
because there's many incarnations of
these covers spa cd
and i'll go into this a little bit later
just trying to put the ideas up front
weak coupling
right so maybe you can do perturbation
phenomena um
in the condensed setting uh in the
interior um
you know so maybe that's in the singular
perfectoid time it's weak because it's
uh you know condensed maybe it's easier
to work with protel covers than
in the condensed setting so it would
make you work in the conformal field
theory which is the diamonds
so the whole relation to the diamond
holography is that if you have these six
operations right in the bulk
then you're gonna have to go from the
bulk to the conformal field so maybe the
inside is the six operations
uh you know um whichever one you want to
call strong and we coupling
so what do i what do i need to finish
well you need to like to i need to
actually take the six operations and put
them in the condensed setting
and then link the diamond profinite
conditions with non-locality
so you get what's called diamond descent
descent is another way
like daniel was saying about keeping the
the system contained the scent is a way
of actually making sure that
the covering spaces can can reconstruct
the lower space so my local space is
actually constructable from my glow
my global space and vice versa this is
another way of keeping
the structure built inside the actual
space
okay and we'll talk about diamond
localization which is going to be a way
to make relations between the various
diamonds
all right so let's try to link this
right so we're calling infomorphism it's
an adjoint pair of structure preserving
maps for a choose space the beauty about
two spaces it's got a very very nice
construction categorically
the chew constructions build builds
what's called a star autonomous category
this is a monoidal category it has a
tensor product in them to help help you
move nav objects around where all
objects have
duals right so i thought this might be
interesting from embodied cognition
because maybe you're looking around at
your reflection and learning off of your
reflection
right and where are these reflections
everywhere so if all
objects have duals that's a very strong
property for a category which is why
there's a lot of type theory and stuff
that works in the choose space
so you also have a category five
forbinius algebra this is an associative
algebra with a linear form on it
i told you furbinius was even in the
langlens right so furbinius is powerful
in body cognition everything is related
right so you want everything to be
related so what if
what if everything was a star autonomous
category so i think the true
construction is actually very pertinent
here
so if the hidden states what if those
are like a pro
finite condition or a pro object that
maybe just only become
uh you know visible upon a certain
pullback so in the diamond construction
that i gave you i said those
those geometric points were mathematical
impurities yeah that they were not
visible
unless you pulled them back over these
covers there's once again a lot of work
um about neurology um
acting topologically meaning that you
your proprioception is gotten by these
topological covers
where portions of the mind or the brain
are actually
working uh together um
and where where portions sort of
intersect and overlap
that's a that's a covering phenomenon
and that's how you actually um deduce
and things like this
so shared action okay okay so if we were
if we're after shared action
you know what if we start looking at
relations between
relations that's where the shared action
is we want to think collectively yeah
in the face of uncertainty if we start
thinking
in the framework of two morphism
then you're already in the global space
and i think there's nothing more shared
than working in the relation of the
relation space instead of being so
siloed
you can be silent in your own
localization but that's not going to
help for shared action
you need to actually so if everyone can
get a hold of everyone else's two
morphisms
you know what does that mean that means
they're actually all intersecting
and interacting um you can take that and
go to in awareness which is what
my awesome colleague robert prentner and
i have been working on as well
that you know i i'm not sure i think i
said that last time but i do not believe
that there's only one channel here
right i feel like through uh shared
action
you could access more of these sort of
consciousness channels
um and so the an awareness is actually a
categorical phenomenon that i can show
here
so i think i showed this last time but
i'll just show it again so on the left
you have a basic
uh depiction of a category this one
right here
my little mouse is like not working all
right so the one on the left
uh top row left
so you have um two um two objects here a
and b
f1 and g1 amorphisms right you have two
objects c and d
um f2 and g2 are those are morphisms
we'll call them one morphisms
let's go to the category in the middle
so the category middle is a two category
oh and i'm sorry the category on the
left is a one category so if you go to a
two category in the middle
you have the same objects a b c d and
the same one
one morphism but look at these wild maps
on the side
so you're mapping uh look look what
we're mapping on the left you're mapping
the morphism
f1 to g2 by that map fee and then you're
also by gamma
you're mapping a g uh g1 to
f2 so this is awesome so look what we're
doing there
now you're mapping the morph isn't
between the morphisms and this is where
i think shared action lives
you can go even wilder because you know
it's me um
so the third the third cat you can have
a three category
um which is the top right piece and look
at that
a three category consists of objects one
morphisms between the objects
two morphisms between the one morphisms
and then look at the three morphism you
have going on
the big double bar a triple bar
horizontal bar
that's connecting fee and gamma is there
racy so you see you can just keep going
and why not that's where collection yeah
go ahead
oh just wanted to give one little
thought on this it's almost like
yes let's say a b c d are people and
then
the two mapping is kind of like best
friends
or marriage it's like two people who are
married there's some parallelism
between couples of married people and
then the three
is like the mapping between marriage and
being a best friend
and so it's like saying the relationship
between person a and b
in the marriage is like the relationship
between a and b in the best friend
relationship
so it's like we can put the relationship
and almost objectify it but not in a
demeaning way just in a containing
formal way
and then use that to build higher order
relationships so this is like
very interesting look at that yeah you
say it i should just give you my slides
and you present
it's a co it's a co-presentation and we
as in
as a dyad are interacting with the
material you've prepared as well as any
questions that anyone else brings wow
and so does everyone see so like
collectively oh that makes me excited so
collectively like
even this interaction is like a three
morphism right now and so
that's actually really cool and you see
um
i like the yeah the with like marriage
maybe you know maybe
if you stayed in the one category you
would have just been friends and you
would have never actually tried the
other relationship or the other
relationship or you can go like
you know twin flames and all this kind
of stuff and so it's actually really
exciting
and so you can see just like daniel's
saying that's shared action and let's
like let's take shared action
to infinity and then what a beautiful
place this would be you know you kind of
have like you know the people like me
that are you know
related to animals too so it'd be like
oh okay so then you have the morphism
between like the theta wave of the
animals talking to like the humans and
then
like oceans and things like that and
then you might start relating on the
higher
like higher um connection level right
not hierarchical but like a higher
connection level
and so you can see that uh robert and i
were trying to think okay
let's let's get weird and like take you
know
the one level of awareness which is like
uh you know daniel and i co-presenting
here because he's
says my slide's better than me so the
the co-presentation right is maybe like
a one awareness
okay and then two awareness let's let's
just bump this up a little bit
would be that you know he and i are
presenting here and then simultaneously
like we're both cambridge apostles
what yes that's the level that i'm
willing to go right
because if time is non-local which i
sort of think it is
why can't we map to it using these
morphisms right of course we'd have to
do i don't know some kind of partition
in the brain
or whatever but we'll get to that later
but that's what we're saying about this
nested hierarchy so use the same uh
everything that daniel's saying about
the categories right one category two
category three category
and bump it to like awareness meaning
actual interaction
like let's take in body cognition and
bump it like what would a two embodied
cognition be a three embodied and let's
keep going up
because that would require higher higher
levels of this awareness this stacky
thing and again the beauty about
this is that look we didn't add some
counter term
right we didn't just add uh you know the
whole thing is magic of course and you
know i love magic but we didn't just
add it out of nowhere this was like
built into the actual structure
which i think is cool so again most
people may be um intimidated by category
theory or whatever at the first
but it's like i think there's a payoff
it's like let's let's put a little bit
of work into that structure and then you
can make this aesthetic and it actually
i think it
helps you know so um just an overview
real quick
i'm going to try to talk about this uh
you know this emergent time a little
better
and a concomitant theory of condensed
types which are proposedly they're
supposed to be immediate
from the recently introduced diamond
holographic principle you've seen me
already kind of introduced that
so if you're connecting this beautiful
mathematical grand unified theory of
geometrized local language in the stack
language
with emergent time that would be a new
incarnation of a new reciprocity law you
see i'm using the word incarnation to
refer to diamonds and reflections yeah
also choose spaces infomorphism star
autonomous
all of this star autonomous objects
having duals
reflections reflective subcategories pro
finite condition it's all about the
mirror phenomena which is in embodied
cognition i think
of course there's problems everywhere
which is why i'm excited about this
right problems everywhere you know
you're going to talk about a theory of
emergent time how do you measure that
how do you actually measure time without
constructing it
and that that is like that's huge
that'll stump me
you know i talk fast i'm like wait wait
so
how do you how do you measure a double
emergent something as crazy as i'm
talking about how do you measure a pro
emergence how do you measure like
you know if you want to do this
categorical construction like we're
doing a two emergence
a three emergence i don't know
and that's what i hope to so like we can
all work together to figure this out
how do you actually measure emergence
it's like do you collapse emergence are
you too late
if you measure it too early is it a
partial emergence and you've missed it
if we sneeze do we miss it is it fast
you know
so our model gives levels of
non-locality levels of non-locality not
just saying like
you know there exists a spatial
non-locality no
if you can put them together in that
formal spectra what if you had levels of
non-locality everywhere and that's sort
of what i'm into
so i call it like a stacking on locality
and stackification i think
stockification is a word like
spaghettification it does exist
i may have misspelled it sorry all right
so you can do local this
you know i'm interested um one of your
um awesome
um um members of the community was
asking me about like
what are you talking about this local
global meaning like the local singular
now is like where i'm existing now and
then of course you know you have your
unicorns constellation time monoceros
and all this other stuff
so that's what there's a play here
between taking an information
and then like existing and stuff so you
can do this by this diamond descent i
told you this gluing and that's going to
be an infinity one version of spatial v
descent which is that peter schultz's
work
diamond localization so what's already
neat is that once again when i talked
about the emergence is built into the
structure
this localization those l maps in the
reflective subcategory it's already a
descent condition
whoa so let's use these beautiful
theorems
right and actually use them for
phenomenology for phenomenology
and so that's already a descent
condition so we're on our way
you know so the goals to actually link
like
strong and weak coupling how do you
actually construct this diamond
non-locality for a temporal multiplicity
i think that's
really in tune with embodied cognition
is to have a multiplicitous
time meaning like there is not just one
but it's
what how could you actually model time
acting
globally non-locally but also in a
multiple way
and that's super french continental
philosophy at that point and i you know
that's like my upbringing
so i'm really interested in this
phenomenal multiplicity because it lee
it lets the individual be
and it makes like one of body cognition
is like what i feel it is
so i'll have to build this diamond
descent and then again these v stacks
are going to have to satisfy this gluing
condition that's fine
our model is a double emergence but it's
pro finitely many copies of emergence
that's what's strange i told you last
time a pro finite set
was a totally disconnected compact has
um hazdorf space
so that's uh that's uh what like what is
that
you know um um what a totally
disconnected um compact space
not hazdwarf so but so the profinite is
very strange
it's like what is that if you have
profanity many copies of something what
is that actual space
so if you have this double emergence and
it's very kind of fractal like
um i'm really interested in that so
again maybe the strong coupling has to
do with irreversibility and
reconstructability i'm very
very interested and what we mean by you
know something is irreversible
right i think we need to go into that
just a little bit more um and is there a
play between
irreversibility and reconstructability
right the descent condition says you can
reconstruct this higher space from this
global space what does it mean that you
if you like
fail to reconstruct so we say is the
diamond x like reconstructable
up to irreversibility you've seen the up
to condition in in mathematics
which is like a is sort of equal to b
up to some condition meaning con
considering that condition
so the hope is that yes so if i can get
this play between reconstructability and
irreversibility
maybe that'll make more sense
mathematically for what it means to be
irreversible
so coupling the strength of the coupling
would be in the levels of the
profiniteness and the non-locality
how many levels do you actually have
there what's those strength so coupling
by perturbation i already said that's
perfectoid and
tilting so big questions what would
actually non-locality be an
act of reference i want to leave these
rhetorically because i want to get to
this um
um that pretty image daniel before we
wait for pause to the next question so
and i think it's like coming up yeah
it's right there okay so what is
non-locality and active inference what
is holography an
active inference right which is this
very awesome
dimensional phenomena where there's a
strong
interaction and you know say dimension n
and then maybe there's like a weaker
interaction and n minus one
what does that mean and that if one
space is too difficult you go to the
other space
what does that actually mean and they're
actually related sort of like a hologram
so hologram is this 2d kind of scrambled
image that maybe you bounce light on and
you get this 3d phenomena
so in one sense the 3d is redundant
because you already had it in 2d
so what is the notion of redundancy and
active inference that's what i'm
interested in
so what is the diamond equivalent of pro
finite an active insert where's the
fractalness
that's sort of happening right the
fractal multiplicity
what is object persistence and active
inference that's tricky
right so um you know when we you know we
say you know the observer measures the
electron and things like this
um you know the pair of entangled
photons
you know acts non-locally or something
like this what does that actually mean
why is it the same photon and so uh
chris fields and are trying to work on
this awesome idea of object persistence
of what that actually
is right i mean you saw me a couple
weeks ago right but
is it the same shanna how does that work
how does objects persistence
work when you're going through like a
multiple time you know
what is emergent time and active
inference where is it more likely where
in embodied
like cognition is emergence so what is
pro
emergence there so i want you to think
about these as we're kind of going
through
what is a singularity right in active
inference like a singular event
what is coupling right what is the
actual coupling what does the strength
of an interaction mean
so if you want a player for shared
action amid global uncertainty
maybe we should work in discrete time
operating grand unified theories
master this local global localization by
these higher order awarenesses
machine learning right operating grain
unified theories let's go higher
right let's not work in networks anymore
let's work in three morphisms
medical okay let's model the brain as a
hologram maybe these thoughts or these
certain chromatic towers i talked about
the
the chromatic homotope theory last time
it has this beautiful
notion um of um equating spectra
you have this notion of uh this theorem
called chromatic convergence theorem
that says that you can recon you can
reconstruct a certain object
from its towers of spectra so you have a
boost field localization which
which is sort of like um the idea of my
top the topological localization i
referred to
which is a way of sort of connecting
spaces
and um again if if
you know you know if in certain
neurological maybe degeneration
maybe the actual morphisms are cut you
know you can think about things like
that
you're no longer able to recall because
maybe all the maps are gone
right so maybe that you could more aptly
model things like enterograde amnesia
and neurodegeneration
so medical level and uh 11 and fields
have this awesome um
kind of new workout about entanglement
across daughter cells
what is holography and daughter cells at
least it's
you know at least we can measure
entanglement in something besides
photons
you know so you need this particularity
um is temporal non-locality is it like
instantiation
without reciprocity advent right this is
me going like wild here
so advent means that you've arrived but
in been in body cognition if the
environment has arrived i've arrived
this is double play
right so is it an instantaneousness
without a sort of two-way interaction
what does that actually mean what does
temporal non-locality mean
i don't really know can we actually
construct for instance a pro-finite
version of that which is again this kind
of
super-disconnected fractal space is
temporal non-locality dialethism time
everyone knows i'm a super fan of
dialethism this is a construction of
logic
where you can have both a and not a
at the same time normally you cannot
right you have a
you know uh you know a or b a they're
you know not a therefore b
why can't a and not a obtain at the same
time so you get this beautiful
construction called dialethism we may
start messing around in that
so it is does a diamond construction of
temporal non-locality fail
time as it fails all pro incarnations of
duration so you can get a lot of
interesting heavy questions with this if
so what are the actual conditions for
object persistence in a non-locality
that is pro finite
how do you actually do that right how
does something persist um
in those conditions how does persistence
work in a singular case such as
anterograde amnesia you know i spoke of
clive waring last time
um you know was a beautiful pianist um
he's still living which is great
but he got an anterior grade amnesia and
has no more personal memory but has a
motor memory
and so there's um you know some some
difficulties there but it's very
interesting how the memory levels work
so the question is multiply profound so
at least try to hold on to it you know
with a small assessment
maybe this has to do with like with
thoughts and memory recollection and we
can go into that
but first a dream oh go ahead kind of
just make a few active inferences
yes there do it okay so i'm uh recalling
my
thoughts here by looking at the paper
which i took notes on
um first you mentioned the dynamic
persistence
and the multi-scale persistence and that
reminded me of the ship of
theseus which is like if you replace all
the planks of the ship
is it the same ship so it's a philosophy
styled question and then we're
approaching it in a
formal way and then it comes very close
to
active inference when you had the slide
a needed particularity
that reminded me of carl fristen's
recent paper which was called
a free energy principle for a particular
physics
and particular is a pun because it means
specific
but also it means particle and so when
we say
a particle or a point it's like that
is the unit of analysis that we can pick
up we can
make edges between points and we can
engage in a higher level of network
mapping so when we're thinking about
particles here
and this way that particles can be
related in
nested uh models or nested categories
i'm not
sure what technical word would be we're
kind of
talking about a particular approach
oh i love this yeah just trying to
give a little little active inference
you know throw out some redness no
please
yeah every ten slides every five stop me
yes i i think wow how neat you see
that's like an incarnation
it's like this this this is uh this is
exciting
yeah what a play that's perfect i'm
curious to see what you think about the
next couple slides
um okay i say but first right so you
have all this mathy stuff we're gonna do
this we're gonna do this
you know uh like daniel said we're
probably going fristen stop pulling at
everybody's stuff ship of theseus
but first a dream because i want to get
like a little pretty so we are
interested in the relation between
diamond descent
the stop mechanism so i know uh fields
and levin and everyone has been like
baffled by that
uh the stop mechanism that you know
doesn't work in something like cancer
cells
yeah when when do things stop i'm
actually very curious about that
um and the storage and reflection and
recollection of profanity many copies of
information in the form of
mathematically and pure geometric points
right
if you're modeling um you know neurons
as
diamonds what is whoa uh okay you have
covers of diamonds like i said um
you know the if the proprioception is
topological and in the covers then maybe
you could actually model
neurons as these diamond phenomena so um
someone like clive wearing has all the
diamonds but
the the covers are cut so it's almost
like you cannot access that
right very interesting when the actual
you know
balloons are cut you cannot get the
balloon anymore
if they're attached to you so we posited
a model of the brain that's actually
allowing for various mathematical
partitions in the brain in the form of
uh profoundly many copies of the diamond
right
so the neurons are geometric points
which are morphisms of schemes like i
said
then maybe anterograde amnesia would
resemble some kind of sustained
truncation of diamond descent why are
those maps continually
continuously cut which is why i'm very
interested in this object persistence
so considering temporal non-calorie can
we model thoughts as pro-finite
reflections of pro-tell topological
covers
oriented and non-locality right someone
from your um
from your community also has asked me
about thoughts and i was like that's
such a great question
what you know clearly there's something
like there's an em field going on but
it's something more than that and then
the brain seems to operate like a
hologram as well
so what is that right are these actual
the pro
finite reflections you know like if you
cannot organize your thoughts or things
bouncing all over the place
um you know there's a lot of people that
are internal or the you know is the
the diamond super internally reflected
at that point so this may help
i said you know to model the state of
being fully conscious
right during dreamless sleep no one has
that
uh fully conscious during the dreamless
sleep what would that actually be
um which perhaps takes the form of
sleeping in a diamond hourglass
so um you know i write like kind of
fantastical mathematical fiction books
and this is my second one
that i'm working on about you know
sleeping and a diamond hourglass what
does that actually mean so you're
working in diamond time at that point
what does that mean profinitely many
reflections of time
which probably takes some kind of image
like this right so i always have
unicorns over because i'm like oh it's
magic
right and what does that actually mean
to sleep inside
of anything hourglass i'm very very
curious because you know
when we go to sleep nothing is really
asleep your system is still functioning
right but
quote where do you go and i'm not sure
what you know i'm gonna
put that out there to the your community
what is that
right why can you not be fully conscious
during
dreamless sleep not the little brief
periodics
right of uh of dream sleep that you get
but where is that
so it'd be something like sleeping in an
hourglass which is actually very strange
and he's like oh god
what if somebody takes the hourglass and
turns it upside down and shakes it
okay you know um but this would almost
be an hourglass without cardinality so
there is no up or down
here you know and so um stay tuned that
book is coming out soon okay
which is cool but it's all it's nested
in
in the pro finite condition if you're
going to say object persistence that
happens when you sleep as well
so to get to some of the mathy stuff
there's some main conjectures
i'll talk about the fm k theory of
diamonds um let's
let's actually look up that diamond
shape again um and let's get into the
diamond holographic principle the fard
fontaine curve
why we're using a telecoilmology and
let's get to emergent time you know
or as far as many of these as we can so
um i may start skipping around daniel on
the interest of time
you know so that we can get to the good
stuff so i introduced this kind of wild
um conjecture about you know this epimof
k theory of diamonds in this
localization sequence which is a
co-fiber sequence
and a modification of something called
continuous k theory so again i told you
earlier that maybe continuous k theory
is the way to go
if we're going to be modeling emergent
time because you want to kind of stick
together small pockets of
of local emergence so this uh this
number two
uh localization sequence is a co-fiber
sequence
and uh you've got the the k theory
acting on the
little sub diamond and then k ephemoth
of the diamond farc fontaine curve
uh mapping to the ephemoth k theory of
the non-diamond
uh fog fontaine curve with a
modification of this f continuous
um working in the the category of
sheaves and this is actually
um this third um left-hand side is
actually going to be
corresponded to the actual that that
omega to the n
is an actual continuous k theory
spectrum
of d diamond so again it's a way of
actually gluing together
and looking at the like isomorphism
classes of what's happening in these
diamonds
so again my idea is this you have these
profinitely many copies
uh that of of uh the actual geometric
impurities so you already have those
and we actually want to figure out
what's happening
between those so like what's a two
morphism between the profinite copies
that's what my interpretation of the k
theory is going to be
so you have this level let's go up a
higher level k theory is actually
looking at
what makes things like unified at that
higher level so it's cool
so this d um upper diamond is the stable
dualizable presentable
infinity one category of diamonds d sub
diamonds actually the complex of
v stacks of locally spatial diamonds
where complex is a
um sort of like a collection and then
you have the actual relative farc
fontaine curve and the dye
so i don't want to talk about that too
too much let's get to the actual diamond
holography principle
but the diamond holographic principle
should fall out and be immediate from
this localization sequence
so once again our diamond holographic
principle is going to use these two
adjoint pairs where these
uh you have a direct image an inverse
image functor and then an exceptional
um and an inverse exceptional functor
which is this
uh f lower shriek and f upper streak
that's the kind of
cool way of saying exclamation point
what's the main point is that um again
we want to take these double
adjoint pairs and make a two
infomorphism out of them so these are
from
schultz's six operations they tell
chromology of diamonds um
we'll actually want to condensify this
so how do you rephrase all this in terms
of a sheaf of sets
like on a certain site i'm gonna go into
what that means
and then sort of uh you know how do how
do we think about holography in terms of
a mathematically
uh mathematical impurity geometric point
the spa cd that's the attic spectrum
of this closed algebraic curve mapping
to the actual diamond
so again try to think of uh you know
when we think about reflections we're
trying to mathematically interpret that
so let's actually discuss emergent time
from that condensed setting and
investigate a condensed version of the
actual
continuous k theory for pro emergence
right
that's wild so the continuous k theory
right so let's use up them off
continuous k3 and then actually try to
put the pro
object together as a pro emergence
okay so here's this um image i think i
showed it last time
so the one of the main goals is to
actually have an infinity one
categorification of geometrical
england's the language program is so
beautiful
what is it trying to do it's um you know
it's a mathematical interpretation of
shared action you are
working across very difficult disparate
fields
um with lots of uncertainty and um
so you have these beautiful phenomena
called langlin's reciprocity
langlin's functoriality we're actually
you know uh
you're creating a certain situation in
which um you know certain
representations
of objects are actually automorphic
forms and so
different incarnations are being shown
to be the same thing which is like a
a version of the same thing which is
cool so in this um
model that i have here so the diamonds
in the middle and again you have the
fmof k theory of the actual diamond
curve
and at the bottom you know i said oh
this structure is you know possibly an
infinity one to poi which goes back to
daniel's point about bringing all the
structure in so
uh an infinity one toe poi is infinity
one category it satisfies a descent
condition it's locally cartesian closed
so everything maps to each other
it's got a kappa filter on it so
everything is nice and contained
which is really nice all right and so
you can also
these lns can also be interpreted in
terms of i have a little note there
about a lube and tape formal
sheath module this is a law to link
once again one of these higher grain
unified theories you could actually
maybe link the geometerization of local
langlens with fmof k3 so i'm just
putting some
supermathy things because some people
wanted some mathy things all right so um
that's weinstein's work which is really
pretty
so let me actually formally define
diamond i don't think i did last time
um yeah and then we get to the actual
holography part okay
so let perf d be the category of
perfectoid spaces so again these are
attic spaces
they look like huber spaces and um they
are
fractal and strange kind of like
berkovic spaces
so the let perf d be that category and
perf be the subcategory perfectoid
spaces of characteristic
p so no longer zero p so a diamond is a
probitel
sheath that's a sheaf in the protel
topology which i told you it's a very
fine topology
which can be written as a quotient um
you know x mod r
so it's of a you take the perfectoid
space and you mod out you glue
by these protel equivalence relations
boom you get a diamond
what a beautiful way of doing that so we
say let c
be an algebraically closed aphenoid
field um it's a certain construction and
the uber sentence
and then we say geometric points this is
the thing that i think would be
beautiful to actually
the thing this is the actual object that
could actually model neurons very nicely
geometric point the which is the attic
spectrum of that c
mapping to the diamond is made visible
by pulling it back
through a pro-ital cover x to d
resulting in profiling many copies of
spa c
so this is again a huge relation with
like
um proprioception by topology right how
do you actually visualize how do you
interpret things like this
so diamond is an actual algebraic space
for that beach apology
and the v topology if anyone wants to
know is this actual cover f i
x i x um that consists of any maps x i
to x such that for any uh quasi compact
uh open subset u and x you have finite
indices i
so that these um these open subsets
jointly
uh cover you so x there is an actual
um uh v stack okay so here's the diamond
again
right so um we can think
what are these actual geometric points
in terms of like embody cognition in
terms of you know
um um you know shared action whatever
you want to think
if if i you know if i'm a diamond
daniel's how do you actually relate
those two diamonds by these like big
maps
and so you can see that right here you
have this diamond
so um the the actual footnote is
calling it what it is so you take the p
addicts
right which is the field of p at x q p
we can if we want to find the diamond
spectrum of that
which is that spod d so the diamond
spectrum
that's akin to the actual prime spectrum
of the attic spectrum i showed you
so you can actually only ever get the
attic spectrum of qp cycloatomic
which is the cycloatomic field of the p
addicts you don't actually get
all the p addicts so this uh modded out
by this zp cross which is a galwa action
um it's it's underlined because it's pro
finite
so how interesting that you never
actually get you want the left-hand side
spotty qp but you only get profoundly
many copies of the cycloatomic
so you never actually get what you're
after and this is actually
has a lot of phenomenology behind it
because like again robert and i really
and chris and i are really fascinated by
the phenomenology of what is
so if we actually have you know um
if you want to think interface or if you
want to think whatever it is
in our organism are we actually ever
truly interacting with the thing or just
our representation of the thing
um you know you've got me at the level
going well
you know if interaction is just me
interacting with a reflection of my
environment if it's actually me
interacting with hidden states that were
probably my reflections the whole time
um what is it are we just sitting around
with the profinet
many copies of the thing and we never
actually get the thing
any questions for for um i feel like
that's a lot of math
yeah there's a question in the chat oh
wonderful
yep uh cb writes according to this
fascinating framework and from an
awareness perspective
is the dark room problem still
considered as a problem
grateful for any elaboration on that and
thanks to the speaker so
the dark room problem being um the
philosophical
thought experiment where what does an
agent in a dark room
do and in the free energy world
some people initially several years ago
brought that up as something like a
critique
they'd say well aren't you very
precisely sure that you're in a dark
room so if active inference is about
reducing uncertainty
then isn't that the perfect state but of
course the pragmatic answer is that
while you're in that dark room your
uncertainty about the world is
increasing
so i'm wondering if that maps on to a
multi-level
uncertainty concept because
it's almost like you're getting precise
at the visual
level that you're in a dark room but
you're getting increasingly imprecise
at not just a different lateral level
like
you're getting imprecise on smell while
you're getting precise on vision
but actually at a higher level you're
getting imprecise on visually what's
outside
oh wow well yeah keep going what do you
think what a beautiful question thank
you so much
oh yes more questions and less me
talking yeah
i'm just i'm uh thinking of it as
there's three roads
meeting in some ways here there's
philosophy you know we've brought up the
dark room the ship of theseus
then there's a lot of the formal
mathematics which
certainly i'm scribbling down but are um
just beginning to learn
and then there's the active inference
community who might be familiar with
this idea of
multi-level uncertainty but
not have connected it to for example
philosophy or math
so we got people coming and going on all
those roads
no this is beautiful so it's like yeah
yeah okay so let's not take
one single dark room let's expand it if
every organism had their own dark
room yeah let's like let's take that
question
accelerated a little bit would a dark
room survive in a two infomorphism
right let's go a little let's let's say
um
you know on an information perspective
is it dark probably not it's just on the
organism perspective right
so that's a actually the dark room is a
very beautiful
i think instantiation of what i'm
actually saying here with the diamond
so in the dark room you may just have
profile many copies of the dark but is
daniel saying like all your other senses
are being very
like perfectoided i'm just playing your
other
senses are being uh more fine-tuned
at the expense of something else so my
question is this it's like why don't
why can't we increase the sort of
bandwidth to be able to be precise
everywhere like why is it dark to the
extent of something else
right um and how do we actually do that
that's that's very interesting um i
think
i think dark room is still a problem has
anybody solved that it's still a problem
right
i guess a problem for philosopher but
not a problem for
the human in the dark room and let me
ask one
one question on operations on diamonds
yes people might be familiar
with the operations on numbers like
addition subtraction multiplying
dividing so is it fair to say that
the operations that you're going to be
describing they're like ways to work
with diamonds just like plus and minus
are ways to work with numbers
oh that's yeah okay it's a very good um
very good question so you know
we can answer that very abstractly that
there really is no intrinsic definition
of a number
you can say uh the number five well what
is it five times one
you know six uh you know six minus one
you have so many ways of going
going at it that a number is actually
just an equivalence class right
so if a number is just an equivalence
class then
then you can think of the same thing as
a diamond diamond is still equivalence
class right
a certain equivalence class between um
but you're in a different
a different structure so sheaves
sheaves don't really add like one plus
one so there's a little more yeah you
can is there an algebra of sheaves oh
absolutely
and the beauty is that so if sheaves are
this like way of keeping track of local
data like a little bag that's associated
to every space
there are ways of gluing those together
you don't really add them
but you can glue them and start gluing
them and start gluing them and start
gluing them
so in a sense they are number theoretic
because if you're defining a number as
an equivalence relation
so you can think yeah one plus one like
equals two whatever that means
or you can say gluing and then gluing
and then gluing
and then gluing so you can actually get
an infinity category
of these sheaves so i recommend anyone
looking at like
um you wanna learn like some of the the
best global mathematics and like
learning it uh conceptually first is to
look at the sheaf
interpretation you're like wait was
addition a sheath the whole time yeah
talk about dark room and mathematics i'm
just like
yeah so operation so and so um you know
bless peter for being
so amazing in coming up with this idea
it's like oh
not only can you put a sheaf on a
topological space you can put a sheaf on
a category
that's the sort of interesting thing
that i'm into so take your idea of
operating of like adding numbers and
just go to the category of numbers
and then if you start working
categorically that's already shared
action you're in this like higher space
um yeah so operations with diamonds on
diamonds showing something is a diamond
okay it's all just a little rigorous but
at the end it gives you such an
asceticism because um i think that
you know all this work should be pulling
in everyone you need the philosophers
make sure we're asking the right
question
you need the you know crazy math people
like me to come up with like
well i don't know let's try like an
infinity category and then you need um
you know you need active like we need
people actually uh
you know working on how do you relate
all this so you need active influence
you need the philosophy and you need to
put everyone together
yeah so in the dark room my question is
it's like um
you know at what point was dark like
light you know so i think also the
darkness is like maybe a pro finite
condition
the question is if we sat in the dark
room forever would it eventually become
light
you know and then you bring in time so
dark room is really interesting and try
to think of dark room
in a temporal non-locality that's how i
would take that problem and kind of
accelerate it just a little bit
dark room in terms of a diamond dark
room inter change the time
interpretation like
in all these uh models you know time is
always
uh modeled as a total order that's
another thing i would like to hear from
your community like
um you know total order has this like
connectivity property that
every two objects in the total order are
comparable
why why do we model time as continuous
why do you model time as a total order
um i think that i think that should be
changed just a little bit
and move it like non-arch medium quantum
mechanics is going to work
non-ar-comedian
with a very specific cut off right the
plank length then i think you should
also be working with non-archimedean
time so
um the awesome person who asked the
question about the dark room
please try to think about dark room like
in in some kind of temporal non-locality
if time was everywhere
i'm really interested in that i'll make
one more one more comment here quite
early you mentioned how
a stack you said it's it it takes in
categories not for example sets and
connecting that to what you said about
operations this might be quite familiar
to a computer scientist for whom the
function
can take in different things so we know
there's functions that take in
numbers like two plus two but then there
might be a function
that takes in a large data set that has
a diamond description and so computer
science and engineering kind of the
application
it's really easy sometimes to apply
these recursive definitions recursion
central to computer science
but you're right when you go to the
infinite level
that's kind of where the theory builds
beyond
any real implementation of a computer
program
so we're on the bottom looking up with
the computer science implementations
of nested networks and then
here's the hand coming from the top down
saying there's a way to
you know infinitely structure that and
throw a sheath on it or i don't know
oh see that's what i'm saying yeah it's
like to upgrade a machine learning
that's another project i'm working on
it's like
categorify it you know what i mean like
um
when you know the specific definition of
stack is a two sheaf
right so it's a sheath that takes values
and categories
that's actually and so it's like yeah if
you move from
you know like an output is a weighted
function
or something if you move from that to
the category
of all possible weighted functions
then you know your complexity has just
grown
probably like threefold you see the
output no longer needs to be something
singular i outputted
a weighted function you know particular
to this distribution
why why don't you output an actual
category yeah
here's a another great question from the
chat from stephen
he wrote if these category theory and
geometry approaches
enable another multi-scale formalism
that treats time differently
can this approach play nicely with
current multi-scale active inference
formalisms
sounds like he summarized our
conversation
stephen should present
yeah can he tell me a little bit more
about the multi-scale active embassy
he you're right on it if you stackify
things
right think of it like this think that
um you know
like daniel was saying if every you know
if every like
think of every network being like a
point
in the modulized space do you see then
that whole thing is just a point
and then how do you actually get from
point to point so is that the sort of
like
multi-scale multi-class i'm super into
multi-class classification you know i
really like this question
yes switch it up to like pro finite if
you categorify the thing
you're going to get more connections
right then you're then you're working in
like
categories of multi-class active
inference not just
one why don't we split it up why don't
you color it call them incarnations
and relate them if it's a powerful
enough category you can put a sheaf on
it
put a sheaf on it and then start gluing
them all together and then i think you
really have a multi-class shared
inference
does that make sense wow what a great
question do you have any thoughts on
that on the multi-class i mean i think
that's what
you know we're saying one thought
and the way that we've been talking
about multi-scale active inference
is like let's say the brain is the
internal state and the body is external
to it so then you have the blood-brain
barrier
and then at the next level out you have
the brain in the body
interacting with the social niche and
then you can go up and you can have
societies or groups that are interacting
with each other and it's a debate
in active efforts does the group really
have a blanket or what kind of blanket
does it have
and here we're not gonna speak directly
to that
but we can think of quote american
society
as a point it's a point and then
it has internal structure but by using
that
basically linguistic token by saying it
is a point it's literally
one term that you can pass then
it abstracts over lower levels and
i'm not exactly sure on um what is
strong enough to have a sheath or not or
what that enables but it sounds like
it's making
these nested structures and uh laterally
interacting structures
making them composable and kind of
compilable
so that we can tractably zoom in and
zoom out
or work with guarantees or
proofs on these types of structures
oh i love that yeah and so i encourage
everyone to
uh maybe as a challenge and stephen will
like this too when we say like okay so
thank you for explaining that for the
multi-class
yeah i agree super like all these levels
yeah
to reinterpret that because it's always
a boundary condition
right blood brain barrier vary between
me and group vary between
like uh collectivity and
non-collectivity things like this right
um what is a group group action and
things like this
so reinterpret that with a notion of a
pro finite boundary
i'm very curious as to what these
boundaries are right
they're not solid they seem to be sort
of like uh
are they hidden so the very concept of a
boundary is a hidden state is something
that i was playing with and i was like
you know what
at what point is the boundary there does
that make sense
it's almost like um you know boundary
and hidden state is like this dark room
phenomena that all of a sudden somebody
turns on a light
boom boundary is there right so when you
have
levin and fields talking about like
entanglement like uh you know across
uh boundaries and things like this like
or maybe the only way to deco here is on
the boundary
where is the information and that's
actually a really important question
but if you can reframe all of that try
to reframe the multi-class
like uh you know the multi-scale
active inference in terms of a boundary
that's like a fractal
that's very strange you see what i mean
daniel right then it's like
then there's no clear defined boundary
um
i'm sure there's if there's a lot of
people listening like anyone kind of
super empath or if you have impact
friends
i mean i swear like some i can just be
walking and like you know
the tree goes into me or something like
that so i don't have very good
boundaries like that
right my mind thinks about everything
and it swaps you know like i wish there
was like a jedi school you know i mean i
would totally be there like how do i do
this
um and i think the active inference
people like are the jedi school it's
like
okay let's figure this out so if you do
multi-scale any of this
play with that notion of a boundary you
know just like you saw i'm very
you know math people can almost get kind
of you know too much with it but you
want to be precise about every word
and we're real careful when we define
things like modulized space like
what a family of bundles means what a
family of isomorphism classes mean
so really think about what you're
defining as boundary
and if that boundary was not solid
because they never are
if you have a pro-finite boundary it
just changes a little thing
it changes the way in which that scale
is sort of hierarchized i think
yeah do you have multiple levels of
inference going on oh my god
yeah if i can give a physical metaphor
to what you said about these
i'm going to schedule yes so let's just
say that you were looking at a textbook
for anatomy and it would say what is the
boundary of the lungs
what is the blanket around the lungs
well at that level
the gross anatomy level it's the
peripleura it's the
the membrane that just encloses it like
one bag and you can even have a point
just the lungs but then if you really
zoom in
it's actually truly a fractal with the
alveoli
and the way that actually the boundary
of the lung it probably looks like a
piece of broccoli
because are you looking at it from the
outside with just a single sack
or will you go into finer scale
and see that the interface has a fractal
dimension oh
see and that's what i'm saying right
like
you know at what point was the room dark
was it always dark and we just didn't
notice it that's what i'm talking about
and will the room always be
dark i don't think so right i think at
some point if you were in the dark room
would change
and so just like what daniel is saying
you zoom in on this stuff
and you know there's more space between
the like atoms if you actually want to
use that approach
right what is that and that's what i'm
really interested in
so you have all these different smears
it could be happening that like
if all of these events actually happen
and they are just temporarily
extended what does that actually mean
it's almost like a time sheath
you know what i mean if interaction is
like this what time spread
no idea no idea these are i think
these these interrogatories should
direct
all of the work and that's why all my
math is like super philosophy like
philosophically i don't know i did say
elephants earlier now i just said it
phillips
so it's like uh okay i'm just getting
excited this is awesome
um yeah one more on the philosophy
um point wait the dark the dark room
problem
so you just rephrase the dark room
problem as being like no was it room
always dark it's almost like
well if there's no person in the room
what's the problem
or it's it's thinking about the person's
the time that they're in that room
because you're not appealing to an
alternate universe where
somebody has always been and always will
be in a dark room
you're appealing to our everyday
experience of being in a dark room
but that is only part of our regular
behavioral
sequences so not exactly sure where that
would uh
take the the dark room investigation
but it it helps us see that it's part of
a bigger
set of experiences or of uh
of scenarios that the agent is
experiencing
yeah and my question is like if this
boundary is like pro finite and fractal
what's
what's to prevent us going from dark
room and then maybe a white room
right dark room white room dark room
white room dark room white room right
or let me ask if anyone knows what would
be the actual
um antipodal reference of a dark room is
there an actual opposite of a dark room
would that be like what would that be
if it were interesting if it were a
stochastic
signal coming into your eyes so just
like a white noise
then it would almost be like a dark room
of a different kind because sure there'd
be light coming on your retina
but informationally you're still not
getting anything
so at the higher level it's a similar
problem but it
it uncouples it from the photons hitting
your retina which actually doesn't
matter
right yeah and i think there was
something i was reading
um um i forgot what it was about like
synesthetes and how cinnace store
information because i have sort of half
of that
um but i was like maybe i should find
out a little about myself
anyway um there was some wild study that
was like if you put
pure white light on the retina i would
love for your community to investigate
this like you actually can't see
it actually negates object vision pure
white light
so unspectraed on the retina well
actually negate object vision
now again i saw this it was in a
philosophy work which i you know i trust
the
you know again i'm i'm not like a super
scientist about that
but that's really interesting right so
just like daniel said
in a pure white room you'd also be in
the dark so that's that's interesting
and so you see you need this like messy
so pure white light
you know would hurt us you cannot see
object vision
so it makes me think is object vision
itself pro finite
right if it seems to be emergent if it
seems to be falling out if you cannot
see
the actual when pure white light if it's
a non-spectra
is interacting with our system we cannot
take it what are the actual
implications of that and can you
actually scale that
right so that's why i was saying with
the dark and and with emergence like
at what point it is emergent at what
point
of like you know photonic light hitting
your eyes
um must it be non-white like pure you
know
so that's actually interesting that the
actual purest conditions of something
may
may negate the uh the organism's object
functionality right
and then we're actually hurting so at
that point you may have to rely on the
higher two morphisms and then you go
join the shannon daniel jedi school
i'm just like so uh
um maybe i should talk just a little bit
more about the time stuff and then
um leave with like another fun drawing
um
this is an awesome conversation um okay
so again we all know that time is a
problem why is an emergent why am i
talking about emergent time
when when we can go so far with these
ideas it's good to bring in
an example like daniel was saying about
you know alveoli and things like that
um the actual um i take care of a lot of
elderly
family members and so i my earliest
memories are hospitals and
that might be why i kind of grew up so
quick um just with all these like heavy
questions
and i remember um you know we were
having a lot of problems with like
the actual oxygen co2 exchange
right that's actually really tricky so
it's it's not like
if someone you know is uh suffering you
know
in the like the pulmonary sense you
can't just
you know and put an oxygen mask on and
it's fine so the actual body's way of
absorbing that
i think is very very very tricky the co2
um you know exchanging with the o2 in
this fractal web of broccoli you know
so what is that and that's happening 24
7 as i like giggle and give this talk
it's like
my alveoli are excited i think i just
said alveoli like ravioli am i ravioli
you're excited all right anyway
i don't know what i'm saying all right
so um but it's nice to when you have all
this
high math too try to reign it in with
something biological so people like
shannon why are you talking about
biology like because i want to try to
find
something here that we can use to sort
of justify temporal
non-locality besides entangled photon
pairs everybody uses entangled photon
pairs
why don't we use like daniel was saying
like the actual system why don't we use
the organism to test on
um so again if if there's actual
entanglement going on
in the daughter cells i am excited about
that i want to think uh want to ask the
community
what we think about uh entanglement
which is again going to mess with this
idea of time
right time and boundaries so we know
that there's a problem of time
um you're like you know your heavy
weights and quantum mechanics have the
wheeler dewitt equation says the
universe is static
to an external observer i'm gonna have
some questions with like the external
versus the internal observer i don't
know what that is
because again i think all boundaries are
pro finite so it's a little tricky
um quantum mechanics is you know going
to say that time is universal and
absolute
general relativity is going to say that
it's actually malleable and relative
right and then you know people like me
the category theory of people maybe time
is like a morphism you know
so i oh wait you know i asked back to
the dark room question things like this
even your local time was it like what is
time was it always here
where is not our comedian time so if
we're thinking about like hidden states
right and any kind of embodied cognition
it's very interesting how your memory
it's not very solid what peop maybe
people's earliest memories like when
they're
six my one friend he's like uh i don't
know like 12 i'm like you don't remember
anything until you're 12.
like what is that so when does your
little system
actually come online is this once again
a play between irreversibility and
reconstructability is it also a play
between your multi-scale own active
inference
have you stopped is it possible that you
were only in your own reflections
until age seven and then you were able
to actually reach your reflections right
is this like people's earliest numbers
so if you're thinking about like i am
that interaction and perception and all
these things
that are feedback loops with your own
system right anything that's feed
feeding back into the actual kind of
non-local organism for cognition
it's reflection based so but if you were
only in reflection land maybe your
memory would never come online
so where is it like where is time was it
always here where's yesterday like i
just don't know
you know um so we say these like you
know we have these existential
qualifiers like there exists
right but what are the conditions for
all of this it's you know we're here for
such a short time and there's all these
big questions right
i want to know what an emergent time
asymmetry is it's very interesting when
i ask
you know why do we seem to go forward or
something you you're almost
you're dealt with another answer that's
super fuzzy and only defined in the
negative right
uh there seems to be like a time
asymmetry and like did you just use time
to define time like
isn't that we can't do that right um i
mean i guess we can but
what would actually be an emergent time
asymmetry at what point if you think
about that pro construction i was
talking about
how do you actually get a time asymmetry
and that crazy environment
right or just like um you know the
beautiful dark room example um or even
steven's example the question right
how do you actually get asymmetries
on this emergent scale go even weirder
with what i said how do you get
asymmetries in this doubly emergent
scale
can you actually get an asymmetry in
just one of the morphisms i don't know
these questions are once again huge how
would you actually have the notion of an
entropy
right in an embodied cognition where
you're you know exchanging with the
environment
if time was discrete this is what i want
to think about
so just like daniel gave us a great
example on the outside we're all so
beautiful
we wear these like awesome clothes and
we have these you know beautiful
features
and if you actually zoom in like to the
actual lung sacs
right very tricky fractal stuff going on
there
why don't we look at time the same way
out here you have this you know like
supposed continuum which i don't really
like believe in
what if you zoomed in how would you
actually figure if time was actually
discrete like a set of points like that
modulized space
is there a dark room in between each
time and that's why i'm really
interested in this dark room
who's to say that you're not blinking in
and out of it like every
plank second you know that's what i'm
really interested in is that
you know your eye seems to be doing an
interpolation anyway
right they've done those studies about
like eye tracking and when you're
actually looking at someone it's just
like eyes and mouth or something like
this
you don't really look at the ear so it's
actually you're putting together an
image of me based on your tracking
yeah and so you're actually doing an
interpolation like
24 7 even go down to like the cesium
atom like time so are you not doing the
same thing for time
itself that's where i'm really that's
what i'm interested in
take the time zoom in if time is also
this boundary this fractal curve
um you know my awesome mentor uh
beautiful amazing wizard mentor dr
lapidus michelle lapidus
you know came up with like you know
fractal curves and fractal chromology
and all this stuff
that's really interesting right fractals
data functions
um what if time is something like that
so what is structural causality you've
got bertrand russell and these great
wizards right wittgenstein
language is a you know a game and um you
know uh
you know bertrand russell saying you
know
there's no there's no structural
relation between uh now
and actually assuming that the world was
created you know five minutes ago
so there's last thursday as and then you
get these fun things all right once
again what is object persistence how do
you actually do that
who's to say that the dark room is not
flickering in and out like every
you know second and once again the stop
mechanism really interested in what your
community thinks about that
right so again uh in something like you
know horribly sad like the proliferation
of cancer cells or something
why how does that act so locally right
you could just have that in a particular
area and it starts like spraying through
like you know metastasis and stuff like
that but it
originates locally it doesn't originate
as a systemic thing
and that's what i'm very interested in
seems to be these pockets
right pockets of the stop mechanism
failing
can destroy the whole organism which is
back to that torsion thing i was talking
about you can have these few elements
that annihilate
um you know these torsion elements that
are annihilated
right at the expense of the actual
organism so if we actually say how does
causality actually change for your per
your turing degree remember i sort of
think that we can
you know in your multi-scale active
imprints it would be nice to classify
organisms maybe based on their
problem-solving um capability
um so i really think there are no optic
boundaries it seems to be these
pro-finite boundaries then you're going
to ask ontake boundaries of what
ontake boundaries of the organism which
you zoom in and find that it's like
lung sac like fractal broccoli you know
and then you know just to keep going why
is space-time only a manifold i showed
you these other structures what if we
reinterpreted any of that gr stuff is
like
space-time being a diamond you'd be
allowing the multiplicity which is the
power of the organism right you are
it is not top-down you are learning from
everything right
so what would actually like a number
theoretic time look like um so let's go
just a little bit deeper into emergence
right assuming it's emergent
what is an emergent from what is the
actual eschatology of time that's what
i'm really interested in
like is it going to be here what if it
just left you know what if time just
walked off and left
okay um i'm really interested in
planarium so chris fields has taught me
a lot about the planarium
so these are the the little worms that
if you actually
cut off a piece of that again i'm not
into like animal cruelty but if somehow
a piece of them gets like removed
that little piece can regenerate the
whole organism and so daniel was going
to ask like
do y'all have any any thoughts um about
that because it seems to be that the
nervous system is
acting non-locally and it seems like or
the planarium like
can they is that like an emergence like
what is that you know so how can you
actually have a piece
reproduce the whole organism when we
can't do that so is there any thoughts
about that like we
lose a finger and it's very sad we have
a stop mechanism that actually prevents
that so i was going to just
ask you all since you're also complexity
theorists right do you also think that
because our organism is
more complex we have a stronger
mark of irreversibility stronger cut off
of reconstructability
my like if we all lost an arm our arm is
not reconstructable given our system but
it is for a planaria
so is there a play between complexity
theory hidden do we have more hidden
states
than the actual planaria just one of
y'all's thoughts on that
awesome question i'm going to address it
with
an empirical observation rather than an
appeal to theory
and just as you said if we lose part of
our body we can't grow back but maybe
you know future
technology could change that but if you
go to an ant colony
and you scoop up the ants from a certain
location
a few minutes later other nest mates
will have functionally
replaced the nest mates that you had
taken because they're all diffusing
around in the space
and so it's almost like the ant colony
is more resilient
to perturbation including extreme
perturbations
however it has less morphological
complexity in the interactions
than for example a synapse so it's like
if you want to have you know the library
with a lot of books it's going to take a
lot of space
if you want to have a really precisely
specified topology of interactions like
neurons do
you're going to have limited not zero
but limited flexibility
relative to a sort of distributed
totally fluidly mixing system like an
ant colony so there's definitely
something there with a trade-off on the
complexity frontier
of how much resilience do you have an
ability to regenerate or
maybe even to perpetuate indefinitely
like a sponge or a coral or something
like that
versus irreversibly move towards order
which comes with the cost of uh building
tall buildings that can
fall down right
right and would we rather have like our
sugar cubes as an ant colony or the tall
building i don't know
right am i weird there would be able to
do both in awareness we could be ants
you know just play um wow that's
that's very remarkable so that example
is
just as profound as these questions that
i'm asking right
there seems to be so many things
happening at once and thinking about it
in terms of perturbation which again i
linked perturbation
to the diamonds as well right you can
you can still do that
and again so that's a excellent question
um
and um with like a more excellent answer
right like how do you actually talk
about emergence and also emergence and
perturbation right those go hand in hand
but also emergence and irreversibility
and just like you said a complexity
so thinking about complexity in terms of
um you know emergence and also
uh i like how you said resistance but
you know with the advent of stuff like
you know epigenetics and things like
that i'm wondering
um i don't know if you put plenaria in a
very horrible environment if they still
continue it seems like ants kind of
continue right
they're like little fighters um yeah and
again who's to say i don't want to be
speciesist who's to say that you know we
are more complex than the ants because
they have a collective phenomena
which is like super profound right yeah
and so it's like are we building tall
buildings to the extent of like
not really connecting with each other
right you need to think about stuff like
that
um okay so that's a question yes
okay okay just uh cb has returned with
some
funny and interesting questions so
there's two questions there's a tiny one
and then uh a big one the tiny one go
for it
no pun intended is can you elaborate on
the idea of the infinitesimal thickening
so what does that mean
what is your infinitesimal thickening
yeah sure say you had
a space right i have a space or i have a
pen
this is my pen so we would actually say
that the pin
is carved out and it has a specific
boundary right um
outside of the pin we would say is like
a measure zero there's nothing else
outside of the pin the pin stops and
then you have like
space no pen do we all agree there's a
very strict boundary line between pin
and no pin so in infinitesimals these
are
these are um in the they're like um
collections
of infinitely small small pieces
they're not identically zero they are
they still they exist but they're almost
zero but they're not quite zero so
surrounding the pin
we could say is an infinitesimal
thickness which is not all the way to
zero
but there is like a little bit of wiggle
does that make sense
so that's what we're saying that there
is a wiggle a space around
spaces so just like i was saying um it
gets
you know it gets rid of notions like um
singular points so we know there's there
was a lot of problems and you know uh
part the standard model is great
but in particle physics there was
problems with having points interact in
these finemen diagrams remember everyone
and so you actually made the point a one
a one dimensional object called a string
to avoid the complications of just
having a point so in math you can do the
same way
instead of having a singular condition
like this is my
now there's problems with that what if
you actually had a now that had a little
infinitesimal so
surrounded by not almost zero so think
about the smallest numbers possible but
they go infinitely right so this is
almost like um
if we know that you know the archimedean
property that you can always make a
bigger number you can always make a
smaller number
always so imagine that that that
negative our comedian
all the way down and so you surround a
space with
those and then you don't have a singular
space anymore
thank you for the answer and the second
question from cambridge breaths was
also is it accurate to say that every
experienced
now can reflect innumerable other nows
if so is time travel possible oh
see i love your community you know
well you know i'm going to say yes
because i'm like the magic person here
yeah
so again what is a now it's very
interesting you can have all the
elaborate
physics on the planet and then you ask
what is an observer and the room goes
quiet
right so when we say what is a now
that's what i'm saying like and now
according to whom
we're all connected right now um i
shouldn't say now
but at the same time you're peripherally
aware of everything going outside like
my
animals your next appointment your
digestive system your autonomic nervous
system
so when we say now it's like now
according to whom are you neglecting
your own hidden states
and that's why very curious as to what
we mean by now also
i'm very you know i'm very adamant about
saying um
you know there is no synchronous
reference
anyone who thinks this now is actually
happening now you've neglected the
neuronal processes that are actually
happening
there's neurotransmitter signals you
know everything happen
happening on neurological time to
actually get you to have this now so
you're always in the past
does that make sense right you're always
in the past
uh but you're also not in the past so
you can get very like alan watts and
eggheart toll here and say
you really only have now it is a
hallucination to think that there is
like a tomorrow
because even when you actually remember
the past you're doing it now we all
agree you're always in this slice right
but if you there's a little bit more do
you see that if you do a formal spectra
with the now
if you put a little bit of thickness on
it it allows
for you to actually have a little bit of
more room in the now
which is just like what um you know the
question is asking can you
you know the now actually contains other
nouns yeah
because um if the whole if time is this
pro construction which is what i'm
trying to say then you are linking
together
all kinds of things right your thoughts
happening now where are they coming from
i don't know and so is time travel
possible oh yeah you bet that's what i
said that's why i was
saying look at me i'm all excited you
know if you can actually partition the
brain okay so let's get weird
i mean not too weird don't do this to
yourself like right now hold on
um if you were actually to make the
brain so that it was almost like a split
screen this is a very rough analogy if
you remember those like
i don't know older films that had like
one panel going and the other one i
loved those just because
you know i think like synthetic
hyperactive i need to be like doing a
lot like multitask
so imagine you had that kind of split
screen but in your own awareness
in the awareness not the now but if we
were actually able to
split the system then you would actually
be able to quote
time travel if time is non-local and if
it was always there
all you really have to do is try to get
to your like
your your own v stack and i think people
are really
what is this girl talking about but it's
like if you could actually
get to where you had those
hieromorphisms
then that would be very very exciting
and then time travel
should be possible when people time
travel it's like they normally
they normally like them the object
themselves doesn't travel and they seem
to think
that you know perturbation doesn't exist
so it's like
if you're going to time travel you're
going to be perturbing time be ready
for time to perturb you back i'm not
saying it will be like a very gentle
experience
but i am completely all for it there
seems to be something in the system
that keeps us on one channel and i you
know i
just to ask the community those are
great questions and even ask the
question you know
the if the question i want to ask again
what is their own thoughts about
why do you seem to be in this one
channel everyone will say well because
there's a time
there's a time asymmetry and the past is
irreversible well we've seen how shady
irreversibility is right
it's a boundary phenomenon and so you
almost have to be like
somebody called me miss frizzle once
like the magic school bus lady i was
like okay this is great
and she's got like red hair and she's
driving this school bus
going into these things i would totally
take a school bus and go into the
alveoli like what is this place
if you were to actually drive the school
bus into the actual boundary
you're gonna see it's not there i mean
it is because you can hear me like
hitting the table
it is to on this channel but if we were
actually like able to access the
multi-channels
you know i'm not sure is time travel
possible yeah you're going to have to
partition
awareness not partition the brain
because you would be very sick and i
don't want to lose you
um you cannot you know but try to think
of why
this whole interface and why in body
cognition is here for one channel
like can we actually have a multi and
that's what i was saying can we actually
have like a three
embodied cognition you know what do you
think about time travel dan or any of
that sorry if that was too wild everyone
but i'm getting excited you know
good question um i have
i've heard a few different ways it could
happen
yeah and i uh would love to see
evidence it could yeah evidence it could
and that's why you know you can look to
um so you know as free as i am in the
math space and i'm open
and i want to travel because i want you
know humans to like succeed and you know
uh
yeah i want or i want organic life to
continue i'm very worried about that
so whatever we can do let's let's try to
keep it going um
and then uh you know something to help
the questioner also is like
this great work it'll be coming out soon
by lebanon fields about
you know um decoherence is actually
localized to intercompartmental
boundaries
right where is it not okay so if the
internal bulk states of daughter cells
may remain entangled
for macroscopic times following cell
division so you have little pockets of
time travel
right if you have entanglement and so
there is like hope
if there is entanglement in the
biological setting um again most people
may think their work is like you know to
future thinking or whatever but i'm
super future thinking
let's try to figure this out you know um
lots of ramifications
you know this theory of extended mind
this philosophy theory i thought was
actually like
really great andy clark right um you
know if you're operating through time
as these series of dots you're going to
have something called a singular support
you've got i i'm really curious how you
remember a memory
right so again if the whole point of
shared action is to get these
morphisms between morphisms um you know
when the questions are asked is it
possible that your now is a
you know like a collection of other
nouns well absolutely
you're probably operating in a nested
space right about like a
a perturbative pro-finite um
memory of a memory right so you start
having these meta memories
memory of memory and it's very
interesting you're like oh i know what a
cat looks like
and then i see it again that is my cat
it's very interesting how you link that
so something as simple as object
persistence right is actually everywhere
time is not a total order
right um and how do you actually relate
all this stuff um
great i i should probably go in about
like
five minutes because i have a class but
i wanted to actually show
oh i have unicorns everywhere right so
there's magic i'm like how would you
so the another main takeaway for the
math take away the diamonds and the
sheaths and all the stuff
is also the notion of a reciprocity law
these are really beautiful reciprocity
laws connect
seemingly different branches of
mathematics so like in the lang lens
program
connecting uh these certain galwa
representations which is one branch of
math with automorphic forms which is
like
you know harmonic analysis like that is
beauty
right that's actually kind of
synesthetic at a certain point and i
think since i am kind of like
synesthetic
but i align with these sort of grand
unified theories i'm like oh that feels
like home like that feels right
to be siloed like doesn't feel right
still be individual but also
be able to uh connect in these like
reciprocity laws
so how would you actually have a
reciprocity law of emergent time
that actually means you're able to link
emergent time with newtonian time string
theory time
alveoli time the time of c of co2 and o2
exchange right how do you actually how
do you actually relate all those
times quantum time everybody's time no
time dark room time
uh the time before existence that kind
of like long like christ consciousness
time all the times right
that's huge and that's why i said well i
don't know i put a big unicorn on there
because it's gonna be some magic
so it'll take some magic to actually get
a lot of time but you've got great heavy
weights trying to work on that
um you know uh like emergent theories of
time or like tricky and they're hard
you know so if you have this like new
reciprocity law if you actually could
connect the diamonds and like
you know i'm really everyone knows and
um i'm really interested in like the
mirror framework
if mirror phenomena are actually how
you're interacting so when people say
well what is the now is it just your
mirror system imitation and daniel i
wanted to ask your community and you
what is your interpretation of like if
you believe in mirror neurons
or the actual mirror system that learns
by imitation
because that's very very powerful right
we were talking about stuff like that
so um just wanted your thoughts on the
mirror framework
and uh the mirror framework in terms of
like these hidden states as well
it's a great question i'd be curious to
know
what a different hypotheses the mirror
neuron
helps us get at what different
observations in the world we could
actually test for example does somebody
who's
not looking but they're feeling someone
else move maybe does that
i'm just curious about it don't have the
answers although in general i'd say
adding an adjective like oh it's the
jennifer aniston neuron it's the mirror
neuron
it's like okay but that's a reductionist
take
because it's labeling the neuron so if
it turns out that we have a dynamic
distributed function
in our brain that does have action
models of
ourself as well as action models of
others and maybe there are some firing
patterns that are overlapping but
there's probably some action patterns
only if you're watching someone else
and only if you're moving or every other
combination so i just think
it's one of the facets of the brain
diamonds
and it's not um the whole picture
i like that yeah seeing once again right
even like even having this
very strange like little piece that's
this mirror thing i just know i was
watching um
uh someone um you know like another
heavyweight give this talk about this
and the sort of the phantom limb
syndrome and stuff like that right if
your limb is lost and
someone else is maybe like you know
touching the same limb that you lost you
sort of feel that
and there's like and these people aren't
even kind of empath
like like me you know they're not like
me coming up and stuff like this
they're like you know less hyperbolic i
would say but um
they so uh it was interesting the
neurologist i was actually happy to hear
him kind of go
do a shared action kind of thing said uh
you know it seems that the only thing
that separates us is the skin
because if i can feel what you can feel
you can feel what i can feel everything
is imitation
then it seems to be like this skin
boundary and then again boundaries are
pro finite not ontic right so you know
that had me perplexed
so i appreciate your answer there yeah
um okay
i think i've already talked about most
of this
the topological localization so when i
said you know you can put a
you know a topology i said you could put
a sheath on a category
well everyone should also think how you
actually could put a topology on an
infinite one category
so i'm working on something like that
that's actually really tricky you have
to figure out what the open sets are
in an infinite category with infinite
morphisms you know
so this sort of condensed framework that
i was talking about
um i'll wrap up with this so you have
this notion i said the condensed
framework was a sheaf over a point
so if we talk about a site so remember i
told you the site is a place where you
can actually put a topology
so we called um peter and dustin call
this the pro-tell site of a point
is the category of pro finite sets s
with finite jointly subjective families
of maps as covers
a condensed set it's a sheaf of sets on
this site
so on this site right so it's a sheath
of sets
over a point but on the point is the
category
of pro finite sets so you already have
that kind of
multi scale in this sort of point so you
do have sheaves over a point
but the point has the site of profinite
sets so you can do this to condensed
ring
if this this is all about trying to do
the same algebra mathematics you've
always done
but when your objects actually carry
a topology that's what's interesting all
the objects so
reframe everything like the six tuple
and active friends inference
put a topology on it have all of your
algebraic things
modules groups rings carry topology how
do you do stuff with that
um okay so that's fine
that's fine the way that you can
associate this
you take t to be any topological space
to t there was an associated condensed
set t
underline you saw the underline and the
spot of qp the spa qp sub atomic
mod uh galwa action with the underline
that i showed you earlier
um this is defined by sending any pro
finite s
to the set of continuous maps from s to
t so that's what you're trying that's
how you can associate to any topological
space
a condensed set so how beautiful is that
so you can reframe if you have stuff in
terms of topology
we can bulldoze it i shouldn't say
bulldoze that's a little extreme
reframe it in terms of these condensed
if you want to get this
very interesting sort of sheaf over a
point and then you can do
like the weird thing that i was saying
put a formal formal spectre around it to
make it a little like
a little thicker um okay so
to actually consider this emergent time
what i what i said let's consider the
simplest case an event
um you know which is like a truncated
perturbation something like that a
topological localization of any
particular reference frame so that means
i'm in the now
i am staring at my reflections whatever
that is
um let's take an event to be a point in
the diamond topological space
t we're gonna actually convert this to a
condensed set on that point is the pro
it tells site
uh the category for finite set so here
we go this global time maybe emerges as
a set of continuous maps from all pro
finite sets s to t because i said the
individual time is diamond which is pro
finite
so if time if global time is constructed
as the sheaf of sets on this site
as a condensed set right then emergent
time is going to result in passing
to the larger category of sheaves right
so we just keep talking about sheaves on
categories
let's talk about like the larger cat
let's just frame it all in the category
of sheaves
and you can consider a condensed version
of this continuous k theory this is so
hard
um and it'll take me a bit to finish it
but as soon as i make little progress i
get excited
a second way to get emergent time is to
take those like if
if if condensed time is local time let's
take
you know uh equivalence relations of
those to get your multi-scale active
inference again
and you can actually take diamond
equivalence relations to get the v
stacks and already went over that
so i made up i came up with this like
dictionary between ordinary quantum
mechanics and perfectoid quantum
mechanics
upgrade the hilbert space which is a
sort of like you know complete inner
product space let's make it a perfectoid
space right the sort of strange
uh fractal space replace you know state
vectors with the geometric points the
tensor product with the diamond product
the non-locality phenomena maybe it's
the profinitely many copies of spa
c if you have that many reflections uh
you don't know which one is the
reference point you can uh the wave
function collapses this tilting the
coupling behavior right holographic
principle
uh quantum topology replace it with the
satellite of diamonds
take your operator algebra replace it
with a non-ethereum complete evaluation
ring
um uh unitarity pro
telescent datum or that diamond descent
that's great
okay so i will end there and say thank
you
so you know i'm into everyone working
together and you see there's draft
elephant baby unicorn unicorns everyone
is working together here and there's
some like
zero sharp on the board and the spot of
qp diamond
i should stop there yeah and take other
questions yeah
we'll let you head off to your class in
just a minute but this was
very thought-provoking and interesting
so i hope that um
people will ask you questions in the
meanwhile and
then uh i'm sure there'll be more math
streams in our future
that's wonderful and then um does
everyone have my email or guess they do
on the um
yeah i mean i'm yeah anyone can always
get in touch
with actonflab to contact a guest or if
you send us a link that you want us to
put in the video description
then we'll add that there but i think
we're all going to uh
go home go back hit the books and uh
i really enjoyed doing it live
oh youtube this was so fun and i think
like maybe the next talk would be like
uh
it'd be fun to do these thought
experiments right like what if
what if the question of dark room and
how we use active inference and this map
to get out of it
you know i'd i'd uh suggest a event
format where we have
multiple different backgrounds and
perspectives and then we
give people the prompts and the thought
questions and then we do have a
spontaneous conversation about how
different perspectives lead to different
views on the thought questions
oh that sounds so great okay yes
well thank you so whoever wants to join
whoever wants to join you're always
welcome
so thank you again and we'll see you
later
thank you so much